so you can be in love with more than one
man
no
i think there's love on different levels
okay yeah but i feel like you can maybe
you can be in love with different people
for different things
yeah like i feel like you don't believe
all right i feel like you can you can be
in love with just one person you can
love multiple people right but you can
only be in love with one person
you know there's a difference with like
loving
people and like being actually in love
with someone and being well like wanting
to sacrifice everything you have like
for them like you you don't want to do
that for multiple people there i feel
like there's just one person that you'd
want to do that for
you so you can you can be in love with
more than one man i disagree only
because i can see it from like a
friendship level was all like i have
this friend here like she's literally
like my sister i'll do anything for her
and i have like different friends
but i feel like that kind of that kind
of problem we're talking about in love
we're talking about friends
i'm actually like so like i'd like to
explain it so you're in love with her
will you will you hook up with her
but what defines love like love is love
love is love but i mean like is it
because i'm sexually intimate with that
person yeah
that not like a different sector of that
are you sexually intimate with her no
so do are you in love with her but love
is love no
no there's different types she's
different
i love my siblings we complicate love so
so you think that the love you have for
your parents is the same type of love
that you have for the guy you're
sleeping with yeah like come on why are
we
like
there's different levels of love
you can only be in love with one person
in one time
that's what i'm saying i'm saying as a i
know
and i'm a man myself
well i can be in love
with more than one woman in love in love
[Music]
like that's the thing about love though
because it's it's a personal thing isn't
it do you know what i mean like so
i'm not because
no but i'm saying love is a personal
thing but i know i can be in love with
more than one woman but even if you were
i've actually been there wouldn't you at
one point you value i feel like it's
just natural for us to value one more
than the other as a woman no even as
a human you didn't have a favorite as a
human being
for different reasons because if that
makes sense yeah but you didn't have one
like
no no for different like
if i have like if i'm in love with like
two women
i'm not by the way this just get out
there right
like so if
you love them
you're in love with them for different
reasons and they
they take different boxes
than the other one but you love
different things about them that you may
not get in the other person you're going
with my point about friendships as well
though because we all have different
friends with different that's not like
sexual love is different from your
parents sometimes
like love is love can i just wait let me
finish my point love is love and i feel
like each person that's what i
understand i so understand polyamorous
relationships right like i feel like
different people do different things for
you so why you love for them it's what
they can do for you right and what they
bring out of you
right yeah yeah that's why i completely
understand it so what you really did say
is kind of contradicting it no i mean
but i think you're telling me like no
yeah but the thing is with your partner
or partners you're going to have a
sexual side of the relationship of
course so
that's not the same kind of love as you
have for your sibling or your mother or
your father or your friend yeah or your
friend is like what are what are you
arguing like i just feel like you're
arguing nothing like you're like
he's saying he has a sexual love for two
different girls
yeah yeah sexual love yeah because sex
is involved within
differentiates that
what is it well i don't have sex with my
siblings or my mom or my dad right like
you've been loving like two different
girls so he wasn't like two different
girls yes what difference is that
because you're getting sex from both
those girls yes what differentiates that
makes you think but what what makes this
girl more or is it like you don't even
there's no there's no more or less okay
i was in love with both of those women
at that time
was that me like i was in love with both
of those women yeah yeah was that like a
like an open relationship or something
no no it really wasn't actually it was a
situationship type situation but it was
in my like
20s and stuff
yeah it was like entanglement
no but it was like when i was in my 20s
i actually felt like i was in love with
two different women that's what i'm
saying polyamorous relationships like
yeah i feel like
literally different people do different
things for you and brings out a
different side to you and what like who
you are as a person so i do understand
like
why people do end up polyamorous
relationships so you think women can do
the same thing be in love with two men
at this three men four men at the same
time
completely like yeah i wouldn't even put
sexual assault i wouldn't quantify that
personally because i can't speak from
experience
um but i feel like it is possible
looking at
experiences i've heard from other people
people can't like even women i'll say
women's experience that i've heard from
um you can be in love with two people
i feel like it's like men
it's about what they bring for you and
what they bring out of you
it just depends on the person and this
goes back to what i was saying earlier
on about
human beings being in a more polyamorous
or polygamous relationship prior to
this system that we currently have and i
i really do think
this part of me that just thinks that
we're
reverting back to
that time
and the thing is this kind of schism
that we're having
this oh men are trash women are trash i
think this is the i think that's the
the
no it's because we're all sleeping with
the same guys so women think men are
trash because we're all sleeping with
the same ones okay and then men think
women are trash because these all these
guys can't get laid and the girls they
do get laid from like don't give a [ __ ]
about them because they they don't
actually want them they just like that
i think so i think it's like the bottom
i know i think it's like the bottom like
i the bottom like 80 of guys or whatever
50 percent of guys they're the angry
ones at women
typically because the guy the girls
talking about like the incels yeah yeah
right yeah
or okay i have two things um
one i think that
women can be in love with two people but
i think is more so
what happens to women is this
relationship they have over here
there's a distance they're still in love
with that person but there's a distance
and then they go
to another person that they're not in a
relationship with and they end up
falling in love with them and there was
just
an emotional disconnect with the first
person i think that happens more so
than them being in love with
two people i i agree because i feel like
girls like
like i feel like i've only been in love
twice right but i feel like both of
those guys like i'll always you know
they're the same type of love
you love them the same
uh what do you mean
um
no i mean the relationships were
different right like they're they're
completely different um
but i feel like i still like
there's a party that always like cares
about someone if you spend enough time
with them for long enough
yeah there's like
yeah but that's that's what i said
earlier i feel like
marriages would be better with like lots
of those
right you know
so
so then you can see that
you can love
right but i would have two different
people differently
yeah but actually yeah but i wouldn't
say like i'm still in love with either
does that make sense
yeah i get that but i'm saying you
understand that you can be in love with
two different oh yeah because they were
like
yeah they were they the two guys were
very different yeah yeah yeah and they
they probably brought out different
sides of you in that relationship no i'm
pretty weird regardless